hey what's up guys I'm QB HP here and
this is the Samsung Galaxy s7 edge and
by popular demand this is a quick video
about just all the differences between
the galaxy s7 edge and galaxy s7 and
maybe which one you would want to pick
if you're torn so this video can be
pretty short because Samsung simplified
their lineup a lot from last year where
they had a galaxy s6 galaxy s6 active
galaxy s6 edge and galaxy s6 edge+
this year we just get two phones galaxy
s7 and galaxy s7 edge that's it so first
off there are different sizes yes the
galaxy s7 is a sort of a mid to large
size phone with a 5.1 inch display but
the s7 edge is firmly in big phone
territory at 5.5 inches and then
everything else about the displays on
paper is the same so they're both these
bright quality quad HD Super AMOLED
displays and then of course the larger
display has a slightly lower pixel
density number but you won't notice
they're both ridiculous and the s7 edge
is rocking that curved glass on both
sides which earn it its name the glass
just kind of overflows over both edges
now something barely talked about
besides the different screen sizes is
some other dimensions the galaxy s7 edge
is 0.2 millimeters thinner and 5 grams
heavier than the regular galaxy s7 now
being heavier makes sense since it's a
bigger phone but the bigger problem of
the old s6 edge was the sides being hard
to hold since it felt kind of like a
blade in the hand but Samsung did some
work with new shaping on the back and
side metal rails here of the phone are
different this year and it's not as hard
to pick up or literally a pain to hold
even when the edge is so thin so the
shape of the edge is still very much
different from the regular s7 but it's
less dramatic while still being easily
one of the prettiest phones out there
hands down now one of the other Hardware
things is the larger galaxy s7 edge also
has a pretty significantly larger
battery now since it also has a bigger
screen the translation to battery life
is a little less significant but I
actually do see a bit of a difference
I'd say maybe 10 to 15 percent longer
battery life in the s7 edge thanks to
the bigger battery and that right there
is enough of a reason for me to really
like having the extra space inside and
then lastly of course with the curves on
either edge of the display Samsung built
in some software into the s7 edge to
take advantage of it and a software is
better than last year but could still be
better here's why so it still has this
tab to swipe out from the side to get to
some shortcuts and then you can keep
swiping of course to move between
different pages of different styles of
shortcuts so first of all you can choose
where exactly this tab is on your screen
just kind of lives there you can put it
top right top lower right top left if
your lefty bottom-left wherever you hold
your hand it's supposed to be easily
accessible with your thumb and you can
have it be smaller bigger more or less
transparent even invisible whatever and
then you can choose which edge panel
shows up when you swipe so if you don't
want the contact shortcut to show up you
can just turn that off or you can add
stuff like a sports scores spoiler tab
then there are a couple more things that
aren't you know on by default like
weather and a compass they're all
disabled but then there's a little mini
store a Samsung mini store just for
buying and downloading more of these
tabs there's only about like another
dozen but hey if you find something you
like you can buy it so apps edge is cool
right it's just a couple shortcuts to
your favorite apps from wherever you are
if you get into a certain app a lot then
you can always have it at your
fingertips from just a thumb swipe in
used to need a third-party app to do
that now it's built into the software
the next one over is called task edge
where you can add shortcuts to different
actions within apps so like switching
opening just the front-facing camera or
starting a stopwatch inside the clock
app stuff like that
now fun fact years ago way before this
phone came out I used to do exactly this
on my galaxy s3 with an app called swipe
pad swipe pad still exists today and
still does all of this as good as the
edge display feature here if not better
because samsung's version here it only
features a couple first party apps 9 to
be exact and some of them I don't even
use so I would love to be able to add
third-party apps like opening up a new
tweet function in my Twitter app or a
shortcut to
open up the camera inside the Instagram
app or just little stuff like that but I
can't do any of that none of them are
supported there is so much that can make
this tasks edge section like my favorite
Android skin feature ever but I just
don't think they even plan on adding
support for third-party apps so for now
it's just a couple of things that you
may or may not even use anyway past that
you have people edge for your contacts
and you know the layout you sports thing
this favorite NBA or NFL or hockey or
baseball or whatever sports teams you
watch and I throw any calendar in there
to for myself but that's pretty much it
you can swipe between these tabs from
wherever you are on the phone and
they're quick and handy access and
that's about it for the galaxy s7 edge a
bit of software a little bit of Kirby
glass that make this phone different
from the regular s7 which has its own
entire review of course everything else
is the same from the camera to the
speakers to the buttons to the internal
specs both flagships in their own right
so at the end of the day the answer to a
question a lot of you guys were asking
is which one I prefer between the edge
and the regular s7 and I definitely
prefer the edge for the two reasons one
I have bigger hands I usually use bigger
phones and two I'm a bit more of a power
user and the larger battery is
definitely a big help here I would
almost never recommend actually the
regular s7 over the edge unless you
really don't like the edge features or
we have particularly small hands but
even then the regular s7 is not the
smallest phone in the world anyway so
yeah I tend to recommend the galaxy s7
edge a lot more than I recommend the s7
that being said thanks for watching this
quick video let me know what you guys
think which one you guys like more in
the comments section below that like
button and I'll talk to you guys in the
next one peace